hey guys merry here with gamespot
presents the mix at e3 2015 i'm here
with Leo from arachnid games hey what's
up hey hey and you were here to show us
diluvian yeah this is a pretty
fascinating game it looks pretty big so
I want to make sure that we start
looking at it right away this always
surprises me it looks it looks like it's
2d but that's a lie the Libyan is a
fully 3d open-world game oh my god where
you explore the oceans of a flooded
world hmm we've actually mixed the
fruity gameplay with 2d where you can
look inside your sub it's really
stunning to see that when you go back to
2 2day again just I can see it I mean
it's really amazing the tech that
probably went into that to be able to
make that happen it was tricky and
you're a small team right you're a
four-person team yes we were four person
too that's pretty unbelievable alright
so what are you doing in this in this
ship exploring this vast open world
looks like you're underwater here just
like exploring the city yeah so into
living there's a lot of things you can
do the main focuses our exploration
building your crew and finding things to
loon salvaged there's also pretty
in-depth sub 2 sub combat system okay to
be effective in combat with your sub
you'll need to salvage a lot of
resources because your weapons we use
those up now when you're in combat
you're in 3d correct correct okay but
all these interactions are all done in
2d yeah so any time you're interacting
with other members of the world or your
own crew you'll be in the 2d cutaway
view
and so what are you trying to do right
now you're trying to get some you trying
to get these people to join you yes so
here we're at the dollar colony just
talking to the citizens here and seeing
what they're up to some of them might be
willing to join our crew some of them
might just have quest for us to go you
okay yeah and when you pick up quests
what kind of things can you get out of
that items and currency or you can get
items currency you might find new crew
members there you might find entirely
new submarines mine completing quests
and you ask I just have to ask because
the world is so big like it does have
boundaries right like you can hit the
end of the so-called world yes all right
and when that happens is it just like it
becomes like I almost like a Truman Show
type thing where you just hit it and you
go I've reached the end let's so when
you get to the boundaries of our world
it actually takes you to the world map
mm-hmm which there's a number of
different zones that you can explore
each zone is very large this is just one
zone that we're showing here the scale
size of it is roughly 2 square
kilometers oh my god yeah and is there
in this open in this world they're
possible creatures that you can come
across or anything that can harm you or
help you so there's a number of
creatures we we started with a basis of
just sea creatures that you would
normally see and then we mutated them
like crazy there's a number of creatures
that are sea creatures already look
mutate they already are terrifying
there's a pretty some like really gross
stuff down there yeah you just add a few
more tentacles to it absolutely and make
it bigger and scarier more nightmares
yeah there was i saw a teaser earlier
for it looks to be like some kind of
real creepy Monster so it looks like
there's all sorts of scary stuff down
there but if you fight it in combat
assume that can help you maybe get more
items that you might need for your ship
and combat or just to help you in your
journey yeah defeating one of the larger
creatures will actually be
sort of a bounty so if you defeat it
you'll be rewarded greatly yeah oh so
what do you guys doing now so this is a
target field that the Royal military's
used to test their weapons so we're out
here blowing their stuff up to try out
our own weapons on the lionfish all
right yeah so there's a number of
different weapon types the lionfish are
you using sonar I know yes all right and
that's a pretty sweet skill just to see
maybe there's anything coming your way
sonar is absolutely necessary if you're
going to survive in this world because
with sonar you can see beyond your
visual range mm-hmm if there's any
dangers out there they'll become
immediately apparent to you it also
looks really cool when you're doing it
in the game say like a really nice
Thanks going yeah what kind of journey
is you're gonna be going on so there's a
number of different areas different
depth levels of the ocean so at the top
of the ocean you'll actually see it
capped off by ice there's some towns up
there carved out of ice so you can go up
to and talk to the citizens in there you
go to the mid-ocean it's more of the
built-up civilizations if you go down
deep you'll actually find a lot of scary
creatures much more danger much more
pirates ready to opiates there's pirates
in the game of our virus that's actually
what just killed us how many things try
to help you in the game so help will
usually come in the form of crew members
okay because the more crew members you
have on your ship the more effective it
is how many crew members do we currently
have so if we check out the inside our
sub we currently have six crew members
okay yes art I'm sorry a little sparse
for a crew not too many people yet well
this is one of the smaller submarines
the larger ones you can have much more
crew members so there's different
stations of the sub that will actually
affect the different components of your
submarines so this is the navigation and
he's adding more crew to that okay will
actually allow you to have more
waypoints and give you more info around
so where you allocate people will
benefit you in various ways yes
especially when you're low on resources
absolutely okay so you can determine how
you want to play by where you put your
crew members and how hard is it to come
across crew members is this like
something that you will like a
crewing one person is a big deal or will
it is a big deal or so then salvaging
some equipment when you get a crew
member they'll either be a pirates
they'll either be crew or officers
officers are like the big the big ones
because they can really affect yourself
okay yeah and uh what happens if you can
you lose crew members if you're a jerk
or if they just don't like you anymore
or are you just accumulate will die if
you can kill your crew can they mutiny
so we'd all have plans for me indeed we
actually did talk about that technically
dying is used the when the sub gets hit
sometimes it can kill off your crew
members your officers won't die because
they're too important to how your sub
operates them it's like in real life yes
the important people don't die they just
don't die oh they're actually in your
bridge okay so that's the most protected
part of your submarine the crew members
that you have out in your different
stations of the sub in the danger zones
yeah the danger zones they actually can
die and it's it's a big deal you'll have
man go out and find more crew to replace
them yeah and you'll be even slower with
resources and that probably just makes
the whole process much more difficult
yes so here we've wandered into a
minefield okay these mines actually warn
you when you get close to them like hey
well that's really nice of them yeah
well it looks like there's a lot to
uncover here and we're barely scratching
the surface but i do want to quickly
mention you do currently have a quick
Kickstarter going on right now is that
true that's correct we're about halfway
to our funding goal goes till july
second alright so thank you so much that
was diluvian and you can check out their
Kickstarter now and for everything else
game-related be sure to head to gamespot
com thank you
you